c'est le projet majeur du mandat de la
municipalité de montigny le bretonneux
l'ancien collège bergson fermé depuis
2007 va être détruit à sa place un pôle
culturel et des logements devraient
sortir de terre pour la rentrée 2020 le
tout pour un budget total de 11 millions
d'euros
c'est le plus gros projet de la ville de
monthey n'est en tout cas pour ce mandat
là et en plus c'est un projet essentiel
bien sûr pour l'activité artistique de
monter ni mais c'est aussi essentiel
pour la construction de loges banques
le pôle culturel devrait regrouper le
conservatoire de musique l'école de
théâtre et le secteur musique amplifiée
situé sur quatre niveaux
le site bergson fera la part belle à la
culture in intel très probablement un
engouement certain qui va se mettre en
place
lors de sa création et qui fait qu' on
est en mesure également de 2,2 de
prévoir un accueil supplémentaire par
rapport à l'effectif qu'on a
actuellement mais on est très confiants
de toute façon sur la pérennité à
accorder à ce type de projet là ce
mercredi soir les élus de la ville ont
présenté ce projet d'envergure lors
d'une réunion publique à la maison de
quartier jouve est situé le long de
l'avenue joseph kessel le futur site
inquiète certains riverains je suis
propriétaire de maison juste en face
donc l'idée c'est quand même de savoir
ce qui ce qui va se passer dans le
quartier ce que ça va devenir et puis en
quoi
en quoi quartier la vie de quartier
maître impactés je viens surtout parce
que je suis inquiète au niveau des
parkings l'avenue joseph kessel est vite
pris d'assaut je me demande vraiment ce
que ça va donner
l'association vélo ce qui était aussi
présente
tracts à la main ils veulent interpeller
les élus et les citoyens
la raison de leur mobilisation aucun
aménagement cyclable n'est encore prévu
la réfection de
la venue qu'est celle où il ya des
travaux d'un montant annoncé de 3
millions d'euros qui sont prévues ce
sens aménagements cyclables
alors que l'aménagement cyclable est
inscrit depuis 2009 dans le schéma
directeur cyclable dans le plan local de
déplacement la destruction de l'ancien
collège devrait s'étaler sur six mois
les premiers signes des travaux seront
visibles à l'été 2010 est